oh look who it is if it isn't andy
lassner
well yes it is your eyes do not deceive
you
um i'm back the ellen degeneres show
executive producer andy lassner is
speaking out
following the controversy surrounding
the daytime talk show
i've been away for a little bit dealing
with
you know some stuff you may have read
about it
on sunday the 53 year old addressed his
followers on
instagram assuring them that he's back
after news broke that three of the
show's producers would not be returning
following an investigation it's been a
couple
of rough months but
it's when we go through these things i
guess that we learn the most about
ourselves and
maybe even some growth
but to tell you it hasn't been rough
would be a lie and i've always been
honest with you
so it's been rough um
but i'm back prior to that video andy
hadn't posted on instagram in about a
month
he captioned the clip quote i've missed
my people
anyway i love you guys i miss you and
i'll talk to you soon
back in july andy hinted at the
allegations against the show
tweeting quote me i really think 2020 is
gonna turn around
and start getting better 2020 lol
i'm gonna make your bed the epicenter of
course this whole thing started back in
july
after buzzfeed news published an article
which included
anonymous claims of misconduct at the
show from a dozen former and one
current employee top producers ed glavin
kevin lehmann and jonathan norman were
cited in the article and were reportedly
suspended
before permanently parting ways with the
show earlier this month
following an internal investigation by
warner media
at the time ichi learned that news of
the shake-up was delivered to the staff
during a zoom meeting where ellen
apologized to anyone whose feelings were
hurt
you know i think that i was a nice
person to begin with and i hope i've
gotten nicer
ellen also acknowledged that mistakes
were made before noting how grateful she
is for her team
i stay grateful and i try to stay humble
and i think that i
pay attention to what is important and
what is real e.t has also learned that
the workplace investigation is still
ongoing and a source close to the team
says that ellen's main priority right
now
is the staff i started out as a comedian
and i wanted to make people laugh and i
wanted to make people happy and feel
good